[Music]
hey what is up guys mkbhd here and i
think i found my new favorite clock that
is not a sentence i thought i would say
in 2016 then again in the last month
we've gotten a new mario game and a new
star wars movie so what year is it
really but basically this little matte
black box you see behind me is called
the lemetric time it's a customizable
connected clock that also happens to be
a bluetooth speaker i shared it on
snapchat and enough people were curious
about it that i figured it was worth
sharing in a quick video so there's
definitely others like this but this
just happens to be the one that i found
but in my opinion it turns out to be one
of if not the best looking maybe not the
best sounding maybe not the best build
but it's pretty good looking uh it's the
pixel art that i'm a fan of and then
just the matte black shape in the box
just feels like it could fit in anywhere
it could be a dope bedside clock or it
could just sit in a studio or an office
like this but the customization is
definitely the best part so there's an
app for it for ios or for android and it
lets you customize exactly what shows up
on the clock and it's super responsive
as you can tell so if you want the time
you can put a clock if you want the
weather you got that or a stopwatch or
stocks or pretty much anything you can
think of and then each face has a mini
app and each mini app has its own little
parameters so for the weather mini app
for example you get to choose exactly
which properties of the weather for it
to show so if you can just have the
temperature and the wind that's cool but
if you want the temperature the wind
pressure precipitation and everything
you can have all of that it's your call
so you can have the clock just stay on
that one face you like forever if you
want or you can have them rotating
through the faces automatically so it
can go weather then stocks then whatever
you want or you can just use the button
on the top to move through the different
faces one by one so that in mind you can
imagine all the different wide variety
of things you might want to have it
display and where you might want it to
display those things so in an office you
might have it displaying a certain stock
all the time or maybe in a living room
you might have one just for light
control it also has if this then that
compatibility so you can get really
creative with it if you want and i think
my favorite one is just the live youtube
subscriber count and it really is live
youtube only updates once in a while
maybe twice an hour on the site itself
but with this you can literally watch
the subscribers of a channel coming in
almost live like every couple minutes
which is awesome and strangely super
addicting and a little motivating i
think i'm just gonna leave this one on
my desk like full time in the studio so
the huge store of all these free mini
apps is encouraging all these spaces you
can have anything from like custom
messages which i've shown
to your latest twitter mentions if you
want to sign in to twitter to account of
how many people are in space at a
certain time so i think i'm gonna get
another one of these for home and maybe
more i don't even know but i'll leave a
link right below the like button if you
want to check it out and maybe share
this video for someone who's interested
in that pixel art the 200 bucks is
definitely kind of steep i wasn't sure
i'd be getting my money's worth when i
bought it but i think the huge amount of
apps and the things that it does kind of
make it worth it over time but i'll also
leave a link below to a similar one
called aurabox uh shout out to
crystalkey for finding it i'll leave her
video linked below it's kind of the same
thing it's like pixel art and a clock
that's controlled by an app so you can
check that out too it also happens to be
super discounted right now for the
holidays so both links are on point so
either way that's been it thank you for
watching and in the comments section
definitely let me know if you guys like
little quick videos like this little one
hitters on gadgets or devices i find in
between the bigger ones either way
that's been it thanks for watching talk
to you guys in the next one peace
[Music]
you